[Music]
hello and welcome to
sophie ridge on sunday it was the
biggest test of public opinion
outside of a general election with every
adult in britain
having the chance to have their say and
in terms of drama
and significance the 2021 elections
really did deliver
a pro-independence majority in the
scottish parliament that could define
the future
of the union the conservatives in power
for 11 years and still
putting on seats and a labour party
grappling with the crisis that seems
almost
existential with a political realignment
that now seems
undeniable can the party ever win power
again
we'll be exploring all of those issues
on the programme today joined by michael
gove who's going to be discussing the
future of the united kingdom and whether
the government would ever grant a
referendum
on scottish independence the shadow
scotland secretary in murray will be
talking about a difficult set of
election results for the labour party
and the former shadow home secretary
diane abbott will also be given
her take on what those results mean for
labour
the liberal democrat leader ed davey
will be here in the studio to talk about
how
his party faired in thursday's elections
plus we'll be speaking to the snp
staffer leader keith brown
about what that pro-independence
majority in the scottish parliament
really means
first though we can go straight to
glasgow where we're joined now by the
cabinet office minister
michael gove thank you very much for
being with us mr gove
so the scottish parliament now has a
pro-independence majority
elected by the people of scotland will
the uk government respect that and grant
a
independence referendum
well the first thing to say is you're
quite right that nicola sturgeon
and the scottish national party got the
largest number of seats uh
in this election so my congratulations
to nicola
and her team on their result and also my
congratulations
to others who've been elected in these
scottish parliamentary elections we now
have a more
diverse team uh in holyrood representing
different parties and
different communities than ever before
and that's a a good thing a sign that
democracy
uh is strong and resilient and growing
but
the priority i think for politicians not
just in hollywood but across the united
kingdom at the moment
has to be recovery from the pandemic and
nicolas sturgeon herself made clear
during the campaign that her first
priority her top priority
would be working to make sure that we
can come out of this pandemic and
recover
that is as you say exactly the same
thing as s and p have been saying
they've said that they want to focus on
the recovery from covid they've said
that now isn't the time to push
immediately
for a referendum on the independence but
that wasn't quite my question about the
timing
i'm asking if the principle of a second
referendum on independence is something
that the uk government would grant
because right now if you look at the snp
and if you also look at the scottish
greens
who are another pro-independence party
there is a clear majority
for independence in the scottish
parliament if they pass legislation
in order to move to another referendum
would you block it
uh no what we're concentrating on doing
at the moment is making sure that we
work together to deal with all of the
challenges
that uh we face across the whole united
kingdom now
uh my uh mum will have woken up this
morning in aberdeen
and the first question on her mind will
not have been will we or won't we have
an independence referendum will we or
won't we have
another few years of wrangling over the
constitution the first question in my
mom's mind will be
uh what about my grandson and grand
daughter's education
what about the nhs care that my family
need
what about the jobs that i hope that my
grandchildren
will go on to enjoy those are the
priorities
at the moment and if we get sucked into
a conversation
about referenda constitutions and all
the rest of it then we're diverting
attention
from the issues that are most important
to people in scotland and across the
united kingdom
and i think i hope that what people want
from the hollywood government
and also from the westminster government
is a commitment to work together
on these issues so instead of
concentrating on the things that divide
let's concentrate on the things that
unite and let's concentrate on
all of us working together to serve the
people who just voted for us
i'm sorry to you i'm not asked if i'm
not asking the questions that she most
wants uh to be answered
um but the question i am asking is if
the scottish parliament passed she still
watches sky anyway
well that's good um i'm happy to hear
that
um if the scottish parliament does pass
a bill to in to hold a referendum
how will you react will you take it to
court
well i i i think how i would react how
the people of scotland
uh would react to any attempt to bring
forward legislation right now you would
react as a spokesperson for the uk
government
well i think i think most people would
react
by thinking hold on a moment you you're
really saying that the priority
when we we still have this vaccination
program that we need to rule out when
young people need their uh
jabs in their arms when we we
acknowledge that people have spent
months out of school with learning lost
and
uh with their opportunities as a result
occluded do you think that people are
really going to say
do you know what what we really really
want is legislation
on a referendum um uh it's it's
to my mind uh i'll put it gently a
slightly skewed set of priorities to
imagine
that that is the most important issue
indeed as i say during the course of
this campaign
uh nicholas sturgeon to her credit said
that the most
important thing was uh making sure that
we dealt with this pandemic and that's
what we're
we're laser focused on and one of the
reasons i'm here in glasgow
is that uh the the cabinet office the
government office and the uk government
uh that i work for is uh has a new
headquarters here
so that we can work alongside local
authorities the nhs
and others in order to show two
governments working
together um and my sense actually is
that for a lot of people who who voted
snp the one thing that they wanted was
continuity
in dealing with the pandemic and
concentrating on that
it's a very specific question if the
scottish parliament
passes legislation to move towards
another independence referendum
will the uk government block it in the
courts
no we're not even going there at the
moment what we're concentrating on
is making sure that we work on uh
recovery
um if they pass a bill to hold a
referendum
will the uk government take it to the
supreme court
we're not going to go there what i'm
going to do is to make sure that we do
everything we can to concentrate and
focus on recovery because again
you know during the course of the uh uh
the election debates nicola sturgeon
uh graciously acknowledged uh that uh uh
the scottish government made some
mistakes
in the past um in particular she said
that they'd taken their eye off the ball
when it came to dealing with the the
terrible problem of drug deaths here in
scotland
um it's our responsibility to make sure
that no one in hollywood takes their eye
off the ball
when it comes to dealing not just with
drug deaths but also with the
uh the backlogs that have been generated
in public services and the pandemic
and also the economy so to to go down
this route to start speculating about
this type of legislation or that type of
court hearing and all the rest of it
it's just a massive distraction um and
as i say i
cannot believe that uh uh people who are
uh worried about their jobs worried
about the extension of furlough uh
worried about what's happening
uh to their children's education i
cannot believe that they think
that the answer to all of these things
is a protracted debate on the
constitution
um uh we all know that what we need is
urgent focused action
on that so you know i'm i'm i'm not
interested in
uh going down that blind alley what i
am determined to do is to work with
nicola and her team and of course mark
drakeford
uh to whom i also offer my
congratulations re-elected as the first
minister of wales
in dealing with the immediate problems
we face
you're talking about not wanting to go
down this blind alley you're saying this
is not what voters care about
but the very reason that i'm asking
these questions is because on thursday
the people of scotland elected a
majority of
msps to their parliament who clearly are
in favor of an
independence referendum that's how
democracy works isn't it that's why
we're talking about it that's why it's
on the table
if they pass legislation and ask you for
a third time
if they pass legislation to move towards
another independence referendum
will the uk government block it in the
courts
well if we look at what happened during
that campaign
it's important to recognize the issues
that were raised and the questions that
were asked
and when nicola sturgeon was on at the
bbc and she was asked what would you say
to someone
who didn't want an independence
referendum but thought that you
first minister were the right person to
steer scotland through the next stage of
the pandemic
and she said unhesitatingly i would tell
that person to vote
for me so uh again nikola herself is
uh acknowledged and again i think it's
it's gracious for her to do so
that there are people who will have
voted for her because they want her to
carry on
uh with uh pandemic cooperation they the
spirit of continuity
in that area and who are not putting
independence first the other thing of
course is that
if we look at the votes cast if you look
at the votes casting constituencies in
scotland
uh more people voted for parties that
were uh
opposed to an independence uh referendum
than those that might entertain that
prospect
so again i think it's it's critically
important to look
at uh at this debate in context
and and again uh one of the things that
i think we should all be focusing on and
citizens
expect us to focus on are what are our
plans in order to
improve delivery in the nhs in education
in criminal justice
in all of the areas that matter most to
voters
nobody denies that during this campaign
that the number one issues
were health and the economy and that's
what people expect us to focus on
are there any circumstances where boris
johnson might agree to a second
independence referendum
well it's not an issue for the moment um
and of course
the people of scotland uh uh as we saw
uh
in the referendum in 2014 they have that
right um but it is absolutely important
that we concentrate
now on the issues in front of us
um and of course you know one of the
things to bear in mind is that while
nicola sturgeon
obviously secured a good result the snp
did not get a majority
in this election as they did um in 2011
uh in 2011 the the snp under uh alex
hammond
got a majority a referendum then
followed it's important to remember that
at that time
every party in the scottish parliament
thought that it was appropriate
to hold a referendum then the snp did
not get a majority
in this election and also critically
we we had a campaign in which all of the
party leaders acknowledged
that the single most important thing was
dealing
with the pandemic and i think that uh a
movement away from that
would be something that voters would you
know i i think they'd feel
well disappointed to put it mildly that
we were not concentrating on their
priorities and at the same time though
the reason that we're talking about this
is because there is a pro-independence
majority in the scottish parliament
if you look at the scottish national
party and also the scottish greens
you're talking about people voting for
many different reasons not everyone
backing and nicola sturgeon purely on
independence i'm sure
of course people do vote for different
things but you know we're talking about
the scottish national party here i mean
it's not exactly
as if they've they've hidden their
support for another independence
referendum under a bush is it
um well to be fair uh they certainly
haven't put it front and center
in the shop window tied up with a big
bow and said this is our major offer
quite the opposition uh again to be fair
yes and to be fair the uh the snp
and the uh uh and the first minister
made it clear that their priority
um was to deal with the the pandemic um
and indeed again to be fair
uh to the first minister and the snp uh
weekend week out
i meet with nicola sturgeon mark
drakeford and of course arlene foster
and michelle o'neill from northern
ireland
to discuss how we can work together and
in private
uh we we have a uh i i hope
uh nicola would agree a business-like
and effective
relationship in making sure that we can
uh work together overcome our device
um and make sure that the people of the
united kingdom benefit
from that joint working so uh yes of
course
uh uh the the snp has a set of policies
and a set of traditions but they also
have
um a responsibility at the moment which
uh
their first minister has outlined to
concentrate
on recovery um and again we have a queen
speech coming up
um in the westminster parliament um in
just a few days time
at its heart um are a series of bills
and measures which will strengthen our
nhs
um and again i think if you were to ask
most people in glasgow if there was
going to be a conversation between
the prime minister and the first
minister would you like that
conversation to be about the
constitution or would you like that
conversation to be about getting
hospitals to do a better job additional
support for doctors and nurses
dealing with the drug death problem that
we have here um i think if you had a
referendum on the question of whether or
not they should be talking about the
constitution or the nhs
i think it would be the nhs by a
landslide and that's what we need to do
well let's talk a bit about um the
conversations that are going to be had
between the prime minister and the first
minister because
boris johnson has invited nicolas
sturgeon to summit with other
first ministers of course this is going
to be a lot about you know the coveted
recovery and the pandemic but do you
expect independence to be discussed
there as well
well i i would hope not um because the
purpose of it is to make sure that we
work together on the on the on the
pressing issues that face us
now of course uh uh uh nicholas sturgeon
mark drakeford
um alien foster michelle o'neill um may
well want to raise um
uh you know individual issues quite
right too it's a broad inclusive
conversation
but the aim of the conversation is to
see how we can work together even better
as i mentioned briefly earlier we have
been cooperating
to deal with the pandemic um we can also
learn from one another
one of the things about devolution is
that you can have as they have had in
scotland wells a slightly different
approach
tailored to the unique circumstances of
each country but under the broad
umbrella of a uk-wide strategy
and in that conversation one of the
things that we can do is
both learn from each other's experience
over the last year
but also develop a shared understanding
of where our priorities need to be
in the future how can we use the broad
shoulders of the uk treasury
in order to ensure that uh there is the
right investment
in the nhs and scotland and the right
support for scottish students to catch
up on their education
let's talk a bit about the what happens
next with the recovery from the pandemic
because we're told that the queen's
speech is going to be focusing on
you know building back one of the areas
that has been
really hit hard by kova 19 is care homes
an area of course where the the
difficulties
in that particular sector have also been
very much exposed
by the pandemic too now when he became
prime minister
boris johnson said i'm announcing now on
the steps of downing street that we
fixed the crisis in social care once and
for all with a clear plan we have
prepared
now this mysterious clear plan seems
like it's never really appeared
are we going to finally get a glimpse of
it
yes we'll be saying more about social
care in the weeks and months to come
you're absolutely right it's a
it's a huge issue um uh with an aging
population
um with uh the particular challenges
that uh
dementia alzheimer's and and other
conditions pose we do need to make sure
that we improve the operation of our
social care system
we also know that while there are some
outstanding care providers
uh people like robert kilgauer and
others uh it's also the case
uh that there are some settings which do
not maintain the high standards that we
want
so we need to look at funding we need to
look at an inspection uh we need to look
at how we can
uh make sure that we get the investment
required we need to look at how we can
improve
quality and helen waitley the care
minister and hancock the secretary of
state
have been developing a plan on this and
we'll be seeing more in due course
absolutely
you say say more due course what does
that mean is it going to be in the queen
speech
well the queen's speech will be
concentrating on particularly
how we can improve the uh the operation
of the nhs uh the additional funding
that will be required
in order to deal with the immediate
problems that we face
uh we've got a significant backlog in
the nhs
well we'll be seeing more in the
immediate aftermath well
one thing i can't do is reveal
everything that's going to be in the
queen's speech
um i mustn't preempt her majesty at the
same time i
understand you don't you can't reveal
everything but you know we were told two
years ago that there was a clear plan
ready to go
still no sign of it
well people i think will appreciate that
we've been concentrating
quite rightly um on the uh immediate
challenges posed by the pandemic
people will also expect of course a new
plan for social care to be developed
um and that plan uh will be unveiled
later this year
okay i'm talking about curving 19 uh
public health england this week
elevated one version of the indian
variant so-called indian variant
to a variant of concern how worried are
you
about this and could it slow down the
easing of the roadmap
well i'm genuinely worried as everyone
should be about
the instance of variance of concern but
there's no indication at the moment
that it needs to slow down the
relaxation that we have
as part of the roadmap um uh the prime
minister will be saying more about this
uh this week one of the things that we
do do is that we have a a very effective
testing regime
we make sure that whenever we we note a
spike in the instance of any variant of
concern
that we surge testing into that area
there are other options available to us
in order to make sure that we can
control the spread and the rate of
infection
in those areas but overall thanks to
the success of the uk vaccination
program and also the good sense of
people across the united kingdom
we can progressively relax uh measures
so
uh i anticipate that the prime minister
tomorrow
uh will signal that uh we can enter the
next stage of relaxation
in england on may the 17th um and as the
transport secretary indicated yesterday
that means also that some of the rules
on international travel are changing as
well
talk about those rules on international
travel and what should happen to the
champions league final do you think it
should be held in the uk now that
turkey's been put on the
red list well i'm party pre here
because my son is a chelsea fan um and
he would dearly love to see the game
played
uh in the uk but there are delicate
negotiations that are going on
at the moment um uh my my friend my
colleague the culture secretary oliver
dowden
is talking to people um about this at
the moment
and so i don't want to cut across that
but i'm sure that um
uh uh uh fans in the uk would dearly
love to see the
the final plate here um in the uk
uh just finally and we're going to be
talking to diane abbott shortly
also in murray of the shadow cabinet
soon it's been a very difficult
set of elections for the labour party in
england who do you think should carry
the can for it the
leader or the party chairman
well i i i i don't wish to intrude on
internal debates and the
in the labour party people go into
public life people go into politics
because they want to serve
and so um you know
you married diane abbott uh kiersten or
others
uh uh well i may disagree with them on
lots of issues uh they want to do the
best for their country so
um i i i shan't comment about those
sorts of things
um i'm sure that ian and diane will have
far more interesting things to say about
that than than i could possibly have
uh is it helpful to have a strong
opposition for democracy
yes okay michael gave thank you very
much one of your famous one word answers
there
uh much appreciated
thank you very much uh that was i had
michael gave well let's try
and talk shall we to the labour party
and get to the bottom
of the fallout of those parties
disappointing election results we're
talking now to
the shadow home secretary dan abbott who
joins us now um
what's your reaction to the results that
we've seen
in many ways are disappointing results
although
we did have very good results in london
and in wales
and in manchester so it's not a uniform
picture but
certainly some results were
disappointing
and it was very distressing to lose
hartlepool
um it's interesting that you pick out
the three areas
london wales manchester where you think
labour did better
places where labour has a different
figurehead shall we say to the national
leadership in andy burnham mark drayford
and sadiq khan do you think that this
perhaps suggests that it is a leadership
problem
i think it's a strategy problem when kia
stammer was first selected as leader
he talked about unifying the party and
he talked about not
oversteering away from the policies
under jeremy corbyn
he needs to go back to that way of
thinking
i think sacking and urana for instance
is not a
unifying thing to do i think we need to
be
building on the policies in the 2019
manifesto
many of which are forward thinking and
popular we need to get the strategy
right
you're talking about going back to the
policies or building on the policies
from the 2019 manifesto
some people listening to that might
think that is quite a staggering
um thing to say you know that was your
worst result since 1935 you lost 59
seats isn't that a manifesto that failed
it was a manifesto that taking the
policies
individually was very popular there's no
doubt
that the party leadership came under
fantastic media attack
but the actual policies were popular
the policies might have been popular
individually but as a whole they weren't
popular were they they led to your
worst defeat since 1935.
they polled well of course we had a
terrible defeat you don't need to
you don't need to remind me that it was
a terrible defeat
but you know extraordinary media attack
on the party and on our leader at that
time so we now
have a chance to regroup
to unify and put forward
those popular policies um just
i've spoken to peter mandelson over the
last few days he of course the former
heart paul mp you were talking earlier
about the disappointing result in harley
pool
he says jeremy corbyn is still casting a
dark cloud
he's largely responsible for some of the
losses that we've seen do you accept
that
long long corbin if you like is
affecting labour's chances
still well
we won hartlepool twice under jeremy
corbyn's leadership
and importantly with a bigger proportion
of the vote i mean you can't say that
jeremy is responsible for the hartley
pool result the disaffection
in post-industrial britain
long predates jeremy's leadership and we
have to look at the roots of it
let's talk a little bit about kierstama
and what he needs to do in your view
going forward you talked a bit about
policy and
do you think that and there is a wider
strategy issue that kiersten needs to do
talking a bit more about his vision john
mcdonald for example saying that some of
those candidates were sent out naked
with no
vision no policies is that something
that you would agree with
i think that kiss darman is to go back
to what he said when he was elected
as leader and he wants to build yes
on some of the policies which we were
talking about in 2019
it is important that candid candidates
can talk about the labor party's vision
and talk about our policies
is it right that angela reyna should
lose her job as party champ
i said earlier i think it's baffling why
he sacked
angela rayna she didn't take any of the
big decisions around
hartley pool and we've not heard
anywhere
in the country people saying they didn't
vote labour because of angela rayna
what do you think it um says about
kiersten's leadership if the first thing
that he does is to reach out and sac
angela rainer who of course is a
you know working-class woman she she's
from the north
some people would say that she's the
kind of person that you need to
reconnect in some of the areas that you
lost
i think it's puzzling to sac
angela rayna and it really is unfair
to have her take
i think we have uh lost the line there
to uh diane
abbott oh no you're back good news uh
excellent um is the
party too london centric i know you're a
london mp yourself of course so it might
be a bit of a
difficult question to answer um but
there has been criticism
for the current labour party for being
too metropolitan
to london-centric not reaching out to
the towns and
the more traditional areas of the united
kingdom that labour's traditionally done
well in
i i don't accept that at all
i'm a east london mp i'm speaking to you
from east london
and we have as much child poverty as
anywhere else in the country we have
very large numbers of blue collar
workers i think it's an
in many ways an artificial distinction
between so-called london elites and the
rest of the country
what we need to do is bring together
hackney
and hartlepool in policies which
speak to the issues that both
types of labour supporter have in common
do you think this is existential for
labor
it is extraordinary when you look at
some of the uh results for example you
know
losing heart la pool for the first time
since it was created losing the majority
on durham council for the first time in
100 years
for many people the 2019 election was
seen as rock bottom but if anything
labour's gone backwards
are you worried that labour with this
realignment may not be able to win power
again
not at all i'm old enough to remember in
the 80s eric hobsbaum
wrote a very widely circulated
article on the forward march of labor
halted and his thesis was that labour
was an existential crisis it wasn't true
then
and it's not true now we need to unify
we need to
regroup and we need to move forward
should a reshuffle be on the cards
well i mean you probably know as much as
i do people are talking about a
reshuffle
but i think generally it's a mistake to
focus on personalities
we need to get the strategy and the
policies right
i spoke just finally i spoke to andy
burnham yesterday who of course as you
said you know was re-elected as mayor of
grace in manchester
increasing his uh vote share he said
that if in the future the distant future
the labour party should need him
he's there they should give him a call
it is now the time to be dialing andy
byrne's number
i had it's not for me to dial andy
burnham's
number but it's interesting that
he's saying that he would pick up the
phone to the
party leadership okay diane abbott thank
you very much for coming on the program
uh this morning thank you
well that was a diane abbott the view
from the labour left we can get some
reaction
to some of what she said in that
interview from the shallow cabinet we're
joined now by the shadow of scotland
secretary
uh in murray who joins us from edinburgh
um just firstly your reaction to the
diana abbott interview she says that
actually the right thing
for kirsten to do now is to go back to
the popular policies of the 2019
manifesto what do you make of that
well look i really don't want to be
responding to diana but i want to be
responding to the country
because dan said a few things that
actually were absolutely right we need a
policy platform
that speaks to the entirety of the
country we had a very mixed set of
results
over the last few days we've won our
moralities back as you said in
merseyside in manchester bristol the
west of england
and also in places like cambridgeshire
and peterborough we won from the
conservatives there were a lot of seats
from the councils and what you might
call the blue wall
but we still got a problem in the red
wall and it's too soon
after the three the triple problems that
we've had of the most dreadful 2019
general election result
we've had the kobe pandemic and we've
had a post-brexit britain we've got to
respond now
to what communities are telling us and
from what i heard on the doors right
across
the country voters are willing to listen
to the labour party again but they're
just not making
that step yet to vote for us and that's
why kierstrama has to speed up the
reforms in the party
speed up the policy making process and
to be slightly fair and people have
completely missed all of this
in the last 14 months all of the oxygen
and politics in this country
has rightly been taken up by coping with
this pandemic and seeing what happens
after the pandemic
now that we're coming out of that it
gives kia a really good chance now
to supercharge what he wants to do in
terms of policy and what to do within
the with the party
and as diane says talk to everyone from
hackney to hartley cool
and all four corners of the country in
terms of what labour's
respect is for the future
you just described what happened on
thursday as a mixed set of results
for the labour party this is an election
where you know
you lost hartlepool for the first time
since that seat was ever created you
lost control of durham council for the
first time in 100 years
you were humiliated in the tease valley
mayoral contest
even in places where you hung on you
were down nine seats in sunderland down
to six seats in oldham council
i i some people listening will be like
you don't have a grip on what's going on
here you've just described it as a mixed
set of results the conservatives
have been in power for 11 years it's not
a mixed set of results for the labour
party isn't it
well sophie i did say that we've got
problems in the red wall and that
includes
durham and sunderland and hartlepool i
said that that is a real
problem for us we have taken 30 seats in
wales which is a great result
for the labour party meals we've been in
power there for 22 years we're back on
the park in the scottish context we've
held the large moralities we did win a
few countries but yes of course it's a
disaster
in southern heart well nobody is taking
away from how bad that is in fact we
should have
lost the hartlepool uh seat back in 2019
we've got a long way back to gold i
think there's been about three or three
and a half percent swing
a uniform swing across the country from
the conservatives to labor so we're
making progress it's not fast enough
it's not good enough we have to
re-engage nobody's taking away
the the significance of the things that
you've just said but also we have to
talk up the things that have gone well
and we've got a lot of listening to do
we've got a lot of speeding up of those
reforms to do
we've got a lot of speeding up of the
policy process to talk to those things
that the public have been telling us
they want the labour party to talk about
jobs
our public services the future of our
economy post-brexit britain the climate
these are all big big issues we need to
start getting on
to putting forward that positive policy
platform that will speak to all four
corners
of this country nobody's doing down the
fact that we've had a disastrous
set of election results in some parts of
the country but we also have added some
very good election results in other
parts of the country too which is why
it's a little bit i'm just gonna
sorry you say you've had good election
results in some parts of the country
you know you're down a seat on the
london assembly in the english count
in english councils you're down at seven
councils in in wales admittedly
you've done well that is a one place it
feels like you've done well in scotland
you're also down
at seats in the scottish parliament in
what world is this making progress it's
not making progress you're going
backwards if anything
well we're not making progress quickly
enough and that's something that
kierstarmer said he's trying
to think about making progress okay
we won the west of england we held on to
we held on to bristol we held on to
manchester united
overall in england you can't see you you
can't simply say in the one hand
we're doing very badly but not
recognized for the places where we've
done
it quite well we we know this has been a
a bad um few days for
the labour party the progress that we
want to make isn't good enough
and but on the one hand you can't talk
about heartlaku without talking about
wales you can't talk about
the fact that we're doing badly in
sunderland without talking about the
fact that we've won
the west of england and we won
cambridgeshire and peterborough you
can't so it is yes of course we're
disappointed the progress isn't fast
enough and we need to reconnect and
that's what kierstarmer said he's taking
full responsibility
and he's going to speed up the reforms
in terms of the both the party
and in terms of the country and we look
forward to seeing what's going to happen
in the months ahead we've got a huge job
to do in terms of recovering
from this pandemic we've got back on the
park in scotland we've done we've held
30 seats in the worlds which is
extraordinary
and i think incumbency in terms of this
pandemic has been helpful
in terms of the conservatives in england
the smp scotland and the labour party
and well so we have to recognize the
patchwork of these results
without concentrating on the downsides
and the upsides we have to look at this
sensibly
analyze what's gone wrong analyze what's
gone well
and respond to that that's what any
sensible political party that wants to
be a credible alternative government
should be doing today
you say that kirsten was taking
responsibility for the results
is sacking angela rainer taking
responsibility
well this is another uh example of where
we seem to be having political dialogue
from social media angelina hasn't been
sacked
as i understand it angela has been
offered a significant
promotion to take her from the back
office of the labour party running
elections to the front office where
she's talking to the country
so in actual fact angelina as i
understand it as i have been told has
not been sacked
but here stammers decided to do a
reshuffle of his front bench to respond
to those election results
from the back office to the front office
i'm not aware of him
she's a deaf leader of the party she'll
take a significant role in shadow
cabinet as i understand it although i
don't know the position
she's been offered a significant
promotion that means she spends more
time talking to the country
about policy using those a great way
that she communicates and using the
mandate that she's got inverted we do of
the party so
that's essentially what's happening
angela arena has not been sacked but
social media
has blown up over the last 12 hours to
understand and i hope that lotto will
will i hope the leader's office will
respond to that and do the reshuffle and
you'll show that this has been this
hasn't been a second but actually
a significant way of getting angela
arena from the back office to the front
office of labour policy you'll forgive
me if i'm uh
skeptical um at the fact that this is
now being spun as you know a big
promotion for angela rainer
when um you can't even tell us what job
she's going to go to maybe that's been
scrambled
right now by the leader of the
opposition's office after seeing the
reaction and you know we were being
messaged yesterday including myself
saying that
kier said he was taking full
responsibility for the result of the
elections and he said we need to change
that means change how we run our
campaigns in the future is this not
social media twitter storm this is
coming from the leader of the
opposition's
office yes and leader of the opposition
hasn't just said that in messages
to you sophie and the media he said it
publicly that he was taking full
responsibility for these elections and i
think that's
the right thing to do keir now deserves
the opportunity to reshuffle his team to
reshuffle the policy to speed up the
reforms to respond to what people have
been telling us
everyone's talking about people are
being sacked that we do the labour party
if he takes responsibility for the
elections
therefore takes responsibility for
reshuffling the team takes
responsibility for reforming
it takes responsibility for responding
to those election results that's what
the leader
should be doing if he wasn't responding
in that way not taking responsibility
i'd be perfectly happy to be criticizing
it's the same as dan abbott has just
done and you're quite obviously
doing at the moment but he's not he's
taken responsibility he's resolving to
do something about it and that's what
this reshuffle
it will be about um i
just want to show you a poll um it's
coming up on screen now just read you
through the uh results
just about whether or not the real
problem is kier
stama this was a poll that was carried
out
just just before a non-polling day this
week asking people for the main reason
that they weren't
voting labor 14 said it was because of
stamina
leadership that's the highest percentage
of the four options they were given
is kirsten the problem no kirsten has
the responsibility
now to turn that around and he's only
been in paris he's only been in the
leader of labour party
in that powerful position since the 4th
of april last year all we've done over
the last 14 months has been
swamped rightly so by the pandemic he
needs time to be able to develop that
policy platform
he needs time as a leader of the party
to reshuffle the pack
respond to these elections take
responsibility that's what he's
doing and hopefully because he's doing
that that fourteen percent
goes down to zero and people see kyogram
as being an alternative
prime minister for this country the
country needs a strong opposition but it
also needs a credible
alternative government the conservatives
can't pretend that they've not been in
power for the last
11 years they can't pretend that the
issues in hartlepool that the voters
have voted against the labour party for
are the sole responsibility of the
labour party
that's 11 years they've been in power
and they've got a responsibility as well
to not break those promises that they're
making to the electorate at the moment
so we've got to hold this government to
account we've got to show what the
alternative is we've got they have a
policy a
positive policy platform and that's what
peter summers determined to do
from these set of elections so what
should
labour do now what is the vision what is
the big
policy idea well it's got to be about
what the future of the country looks
like in a post-brexit
environment we've got to make sure that
what should it be what is the vision for
that
well the vision's got to be about
people's jobs it's got to be about
people's livelihoods it's got to be
about how we fund our public services
it's got to be about giving power to
communities it's got to be about
investing
and the places that felt they've been
left behind it's got to be about
responding to what the ordinary voter
wants the other realtor wants
a safe job they want progression in the
workplace they want good pay they want
well rewarded they want fairness they
want a safety net
they want their children to do well in
school these things aren't difficult
the policy the policy platform to get us
forward in terms of those narratives
is the thing that needs to be worked on
but that's what we are pretending to do
and that's what work here is determined
to put together in terms of both his
team
and the policy platform going forward
okay um i just want to talk to you about
scotland
as we finish um there's now a majority
in the scottish parliament
for independence if you look at the
scottish national party
and also the scottish greens so if the
scottish parliament does pass
legislation for another independence
referendum
should the uk government take it to
court or should that be respected
well let's go back to just before the
election there was also
a pro-independence majority in the
previous scottish parliament the best
and peanut bean so this
isn't new the s p talked up getting the
majority said that would be the settled
will
of the scottish people and fell short
from doing that an important thing to
realize from these elections which the
critical for all sides of this debate
is that scotland's completely split down
the middle in terms of the constituency
vote
pro-independence parties just fell short
of 50 percent
and on the regional list vote just got
over at 50
so scotland's completely and utterly
split there in the middle the first
minister promised that this election
would be about covert recovery
and we will be holding her to that and
if she brings a bill
to parliament about a referendum because
she promised it would be about covert
recovery we will certainly not support
that i can't talk for the
prime minister the prime minister said
he would block a second independence
referendum the conservatives campaigned
on that but it looks if they probably
will break the promise and watching
michael gove earlier he didn't seem to
want to answer the question at all about
what the uk government would do but what
we are doing and what our msps will be
doing when they go back to parliament on
thursday
is something that's so focused on what
everyone promised at this election
which is covered recovery that's the
priorities of the scottish people that's
the priorities of our msps when they go
back
into that chamber and it should be the
priority for everyone and both
governments the uk and the scottish
government
has to work together to make this work
otherwise scotland and the rest of the
uk
will be much diminished now if i can
just reflect on what mark drakeford
the labour first minister in wales said
after the election results
uh this week he said that he was going
to go back into parliament
uh next week he was going to concentrate
fully on private recovery
and show an aspirational bright future
for our radical wales
wouldn't it be great if that's what the
first minister said as well instead of
going back into this quagmire
and this divisiveness of another second
independence referendum that quite
frankly
is not the priority of the scottish
people at the moment okay
uh murray thank you very much for being
on the program today thank you
slavers shadow scotland secretary in
murray there now we know of course this
morning that the prime minister has
invited
the leaders of the devolved nations to a
summit on how team uk as he called it
can recover from the pandemic together
but the snp's fourth scottish parliament
election win in a row has seen the first
minister nicola sturgeon feeling
more bullish than ever about vacating
scotland seat at the uk
table even if her party fell one seat
short of that crucial
overall majority well let's get more on
this now we're joined by the authorities
deputy leader
keith brown thank you very much for
being uh with us
at the start of the campaign there was a
lot of optimism shall we say about
the uh snp getting that overall
majority you didn't manage to do it it
certainly would have made the push for a
second referendum
a bit easier wouldn't it are you
disappointed you fell short
disappointed in a historic fourth win
for the snp
no i think at the start of a campaign
you have three goals in mind one is to
win the election which we did in
spectacular fashion to increase the
number of votes you have which you've
done
more votes at this selection than any
other party has ever achieved
in the devolved parliament and also more
seats we won seats the tories lost seats
labour lost seats the snp have done all
the these three things and also of
course there is
an independence majority in the
parliament so an astonishingly good
result for the snp and i believe for
scottish democracy
uh you're talking there about the
pro-independence majority in the
scottish parliament we've been talking
about it a lot
on the show as well um a majority of
msps support independence if you look at
the snp and scottish greens
but if you look at vote shares the
pro-independence parties
won less than 50 yourself from the
scottish greens
and the anti-referendum parties won more
than 50
so on that basis you know one person one
vote
then actually would it be democratic to
push for another referendum
this is just an absolutely bizarre
argument david cameron got around 36
of the vote when he took forward a
brexit referendum of course against the
wishes of people in scotland
if the election we had yesterday had
been held at westminster
on constituencies we'd have a majority
of about 400
so the idea that in a parliamentary
party election you don't have a mandate
when the main party and other parties
have more than 50 percent
of the seats it really comes down to a
vote in the parliament and i didn't hear
anybody saying during all the endless
brexit votes that we had when different
parties voted for the same thing on many
occasions
that that invalidated the result this is
democracy
the snp have done extremely well we will
have a majority for
an independence referendum in the
parliament but for the first 100 days as
has been made clear by the first
minister we'll be concentrating on the
recovery
the health service education and the
health of the people in scotland
yeah it's interesting so you're talking
about focusing on the recovery
um at what point do you start to push
for
another independence referendum the
reason i'm asking this question because
it feels to me a little bit
like the timeline is slipping that it's
in nobody's interest to do it right now
including your own
is that fair when do you want to see
another referendum
i think most people in the independence
maybe we want to see it as soon as
possible but they also realize that
we're in the grip of a pandemic and that
is still
a very real threat we've seen a slight
uptick in some areas in scotland in
recent days in terms of the
incidence of coronavirus and that's got
to be the priority for everybody i think
all the parties
have agreed on that i think it's also
true to say though that the election
we've just had was not a normal election
even though we had a fantastic increase
in turnout there wasn't the usual
hustings the public debates the town
hall meetings
and i think we all want to see when
there is to be the independence
referendum a much more full-blooded
engaged campaign on that issue so
we'll know when the public health
situation is right and the scottish
parliament will take the decision as to
exactly when that happens
and when the referendum should be can
you not give us any guidance
at all on when you think it would be the
right time to
you know push for another referendum
well i i don't think you've seen
anything different from boris johnson
mark drakeford or nicola sturgeon
who do not predict when the end of the
pandemic is because we know how
unpredictable this disease is and also
because of the new variants as well so
it's a hostage to fortune to start
putting a time limit on that but we will
know when it's over we will know when
it's safe to have
that full bloody campaign that i've
mentioned but until that happens
our concentration has to be focused on
the
pandemic making sure that we drive down
coronavirus and look after the public
health of the people in scotland
can you guarantee a referendum by the
end of 2024 as you've previously said
well the only caveat to that of course
would be the pandemic but yes that's our
intentions to have
that referendum i've said as soon as
possible and we're making fantastic
progress with the
pandemic in the fight against
coronavirus as you can see in the
figures now
but that threat is still there and of
course there's also the threat
of new variants of the virus so nobody
can put time limits on that is
no politician is doing that just now and
it's unreasonable i think to ask them to
do that
but at the earliest possible opportunity
when it's safe to do so we will move to
have the referendum what the one that
scotland has just voted for in massive
numbers
if boris johnson refuses to grant
another referendum or if the supreme
court finds it would be illegal because
it doesn't fall under the pounds of the
scottish parliament to move the
legislation
what would you then do would you just
hold an independence referendum anyway
well first of all i've never believed
that boris johnson would continue to
as he would see veto scottish democracy
after the result of an election like the
one we had yesterday i've never believed
that would be the case
and i think you're seeing already some
changing language from the uk government
which was inevitable
it's also true to say that boris johnson
is a man that's not a stranger to
u-turns if you think about
just his manifesto at the recent
election he said he wouldn't reduce the
size of the armed forces and then
promptly did
he signed an international treaty which
he then renounced pretty much as soon as
he had signed it
so boris johnson will change to take
account of the political circumstances
in scotland
and we will proceed with the referendum
the referendum will happen it's going to
happen
i think the conservatives many of whom
have spoken to understand that's the
case
the only issue is when the time is right
and the time will be right when it's
safe to have that referendum
i understand that you know you don't
believe boris johnson but i'm not asking
you what you think boris johnson would
i'm asking what you will do
if either the supreme court says the
referendum would be
you know effective an illegal one or if
boris johnson refuses to grant it
would you hold a referendum anyway in
those circumstances
well you'd ask me to jump past what i
don't believe and i don't believe that
boris johnson
will as you say veto this so i don't
think that's going to happen so you're
now into hypothetical situation
and of course it wouldn't be the
scottish government to be taking legal
action scottish government will proceed
if the scottish parliament votes for the
referendum we would like to do that in
the basis of a section 30 agreement that
makes sure it's all agreed as it was
back in 2014
or previously 2012 with david cameron
we'd like to do it on that basis that's
the right way to do it
and i believe that will happen i think
that's what's going to happen but in the
event that there's any
denial of scottish democracy in the
event that boris johnson
johnson tries to do a trump and try and
use the legal process to subvert
scottish democracy
i believe the referendum will still
happen
okay snp deputy leader keith brown there
thank you very much for being on the
program
this morning
we've been discussing uh the results of
course
of the 2021 uh elections talking to the
labour party
about their performance we can focus now
on what happened with the
liberal democrats and we can talk to
their
leader davey who joins us now in the
studio thank you very much for being
a pleasure with us um not much sign of a
lib dem resurgence was there
well liberal democrats scored 17 of the
national
vote and for nearly one in five voters
to vote liberal democrat
um i think is a good result and this
wasn't just the 17 percent that liberal
democrats scored
it was where we scored them uh we made
gains from both late and conservative
but particularly against the
conservatives
in tory heartland from cambridgeshire to
surrey to hertfordshire to wiltshire
you know we made gains in stockport from
swords in the north
wokingham guildford and the significance
of these gains
sophie is that they're the sorts of
council areas where we can
take that to westminster levels and we
can win the constituencies
and i think that's makes progress i mean
my mission as liberal democrat leader
is to make the liberal caps as strong as
possible to defeat as many conservative
mps
at the next election as possible and
judged on that mission
on thursday night we made real progress
do you think that you're setting your
standards a bit low here though
genuinely like
if you really think that it was real
progress for your party
uh the results that happened before i
mean you're starting from an incredibly
low base here you're down i've seen
scotland you're down council six in
england
you made zero progress in wales in terms
of seats
you're pushing to fourth place in the
london mayoral race
i mean don't you need to front up and
take a bit more responsibility than that
well first of all your analysis of the
council seats is a little bit early for
you there might be saying so there's
still
counsel's seats to be counted and uh you
know we've got real areas where we're
strong in places like
oxfordshire and saint albans but i said
when i became the leader of the liberal
democrats eight months ago
that we had some real challenges and i'm
happy to repeat that to you today
yeah but we've made progress that's my
point in in eight months
i set myself the task that these
elections
we would make progress in the areas that
we needed to win in the next general
election where we can beat
conservative mps and in large parts of
the country
now it's really clear if you want to
beat the conservatives
you vote liberal democrat and you know
people are talking about the red wall
and the conservatives chipping at the
red wall
there's a blue wall uh in the
conservative heartlands and liberal
democrats are chipping away
at that blue wall and i want those to be
our new heartlands
in that blue wall though you know the
chips you're making are pretty small
they're not like you know massive
hammer blows yet are they and this is
the concept of
the concept apart has been in power for
11 years the labour party you know we've
discussed are
in an existential crisis this should be
a golden opportunity for you guys
shouldn't it and yet here you are just
making a couple of games here and there
you know taking
the odd council to no overall control i
mean it
shouldn't you be setting your sights a
bit higher than this well do we want to
make even more progress of course we do
but this is solid progress i mean the
seven gains in wiltshire was a really
highlight the five games in
cambridgeshire we took as you say power
away from the conservatives
these are areas of our strengths and you
know i go back to
key areas where we have real prospects
to beat conservative mps in the next
election places like cheadle and hazel
grove like guilford
um you know these are places where we
made real progress
and so uh if you're thinking about next
general election which uh indeed sky was
doing i mean
uh your own political reporter sam coats
when he was showing that we won 70
percent of the vote
he was making the point this liberal
democrats eating into the conservative
vote
and in your own projections you don't
see the greens winning any seats
you see labour winning a few seats you
see liberal democrats winning more seats
against the conservatives
because you do very well usually in
local elections normally a lot better
than this
well i mean we are very strong in local
government you're right we've got over
two and a half thousand councils across
the country
and local government is very important
to what liberal democrats are about
but we have to rebuild that base as we
did on thursday night
so that we can then translate that into
victors against the conservatives of the
next general election
so you know i i think in that frame in
that mission that we've set ourselves
we made real progress how concerned are
you by the green party
i know you say that the projection shows
they wouldn't win seats but at the same
time they had a
pretty good night didn't they and in
some areas you know
they push you into a distant fourth
place they put on
a considerable number of seats are you
worried that
the green parties are starting to emerge
as the traditional
you know liberal democrat party where if
you don't like the label conservatives
and you vote lib dems well now it looks
like people might be increasingly voting
green
i'm not worried because there were over
500
liberal democrat councillors elected on
thursday night and just a hundred of
uh green councillors so we remain far
stronger
if you look at the progress the progress
that the green's been making is
dramatically
uh better than the lib dance well i have
to say it's the number of councillors
you got elected
that's the real bar and on that we
completely
uh overwhelm the greens and the key
thing is for the next general election
if well if you've just done the number
of councils then you would say labour
had a stonking night which is clearly
not the case is it but
the point is of the next general
election who which is the party that can
beat conservative mps
and it's pretty clear from skye's own
analysis it's not mine
from some coats from sky that it's the
liberal democrats if you want to be
conservative mps
in large swathes of england liberal
democrats are
building our strength to be able to do
that and i really hope people recognize
that because
i know there are green voters who yes
they vote green in one or two local
elections
but they know that the uh in
parliamentary constituencies
uh across england it's the liberal
democrats that have a powerful vote
in the first pass of the post system to
beat the conservatives
i want to talk to you about scotland now
the the really huge issues that has
emerged
from these elections there's now a
majority for
independence supporting parties in
hollywood if the scottish
parliament votes for another
independence referendum should the uk
government grant that
well willie rainey and the scottish
liberal democrats fought this election
campaign
against a second independence referendum
we made the argument in fact i think be
the first party to do it that we should
be putting the recovery first
we've had the deepest economic recession
for 300 years the worst health crisis
for a
hundred years and liberal democrats made
the argument that scottish people are
worried about their health
their care their jobs their businesses
and i think that is absolutely the issue
now confronting scotland frankly the
whole of the united kingdom
and so liberal democrats will say to
whoever please put recovery first
that's in the interest of the people we
are we are elected to represent
it feels like i'm getting the kind the
same answer from everyone about recovery
first you know
from michael gove um from keith brown
from yourself
and the question that i'm trying to get
to is
if the scottish parliament votes in
favor of another referendum
should the uk government grant it i'm
struggling to get a straight answer from
anyone i wonder if
you can you help me well you're right it
is boris johnson who has to make that
decision
uh and i'm not sure if he's going to be
picking up the phone to
myself to ask my my opinion but what i
can say is
liberal democrats fought that election
against
a independence referendum that is our
democratic mandate
that is our position our position is
with the economy and
the health of our country and such such
dire straits we need to be focusing on
the people's concerns
and you know i i i really worry that if
we have
a years of division
dividing scotland dividing the united
kingdom um that will undermine the
recovery even if the scottish department
votes for another referendum you don't
think it should happen
is that the position well um we fought
um
uh against that i i know i know the
manifesto that you
you've you really will you ready willie
renny
and the liberal democrat msps that have
been elected and by the way willie
rennie got the best ever constituency
result
of any scottish msp ever so he got a
really strong mandate for the case he
was making
uh we saw alex call hamilton and edward
weston really well
if the scottish parliament votes for
another referendum
should that go ahead when i was making
is that
msps um who got really good results uh
in their constituencies have a mandate
to oppose that
and i'm not going to undermine the case
they made so well
in their constituencies across scotland
that recovery should come first
okay uh just finally um i'm interested
uh to hear your thoughts on kirsten with
difficult
uh day for labour of course with those
election results
does he need to think about his position
listen i think all opposition parties
had a tough time on thursday night
i think it's becoming uh most
commentators are admitting that it was
the incumbents
that did well whether it's the labour
party in wales the smp in scotland
or the conservatives in in westminster
because not surprisingly
voters kept seeing them on their tv
throughout the whole pandemic
and that has made it more difficult to
campaign and for the liberal democrats
you know normally we are
out there campaigning knock on knocking
on people's doors getting our messages
over that's where we are strong
and you know i'm absolutely delighted
actually by the fact we still got 17
percent of the national vote
despite the fact we weren't able to
campaign that we still made these
massive gains against the conservatives
in key areas
for us of the next general elections
yeah but but all i'm saying is i i have
some sympathy with opposition parties
who had the same challenges that liberal
democrats had now actually little
narcotics despite those challenges
made progress okay uh thank you very
much for coming on the programme with uh
sorry davey there thank you very much
well that's it for this week's edition
of sophie ridge on a sunday but do join
us
after the break for sophie ridge the
take where we are going to be talking
over everything that we've just heard
from our interviews with our political
correspondent rob powell so don't go
[Music]
anywhere
[Music]
foreign